Hello Freak bitches.
Do you have this a desire to
like keep upping the ante?
Is that an issue?
Um,
not really.
No.
I just like,
ultimately I just like creating stuff
and I liked making videos and I liked
exploring places.
I like heights,
I like jumping between stuff and Latin.
Like the natural progression for me is to,
is to get higher and things get bigger.
That's just how it is.
So it just happens but bright.
But I'm not thinking about it.
I'm not thinking like,
okay,
I've just released this,
so now I need to do something bigger.
Like it's just there.
It's just natural mean.
So how do you go about making a video?
If you decide I'm going
to make a new video,
what do you have a thought in your head?
Like I need to get on the Eiffel Tower.
Like what do you do it?
You know what the Eiffel Tower was never,
never a plan.
I never saw.
Let's go to Paris and do the Eiffel Tower.
Did you do the Eiffel Tower?
The Eiffel Tower?
So how'd you do it?
If it's not a plan,
how'd you do it?
So I was in Denmark just traveling around
with a bunch of friends and instead of
getting in the minivan and driving
all the way back to London,
I was like,
no,
I don't want to sit in a van for 15 hours.
Let's just fly somewhere
and continue this adventure.
So me and my friend flew to Paris and
then the next day we ended up climbing.
Now for tower.
Do you think this kind of stuff was being
done before people were videotaping?
It must've been.
I feel like for certain
people it's just a,
it's just in them to kind of explore
places you shouldn't really explore and I
think he's,
yeah.
Well for you it seems like
something that was fostered though,
right?
Because you started off just doing the
par course stuff and this became of it.
But you know what?
When I was a kid,
I was like,
I was annoyed little kid.
I was always to do things I shouldn't.
No Way.
Yeah,
man.
Now I'm just a big,
just a big version of what I was then.
Wow.
Ooh,
some pretty cool videos.
If you look up on youtube of like urban
exploration or people were finding weird
pathways and like,
Oh shit,
looked on 60 feet underground,
we made it and there's this shit
that's been buried under here.
Wonder why it's buried and look old
electronics and stuff like that.
Like under like uncovering
the hatch and lost.
So it'll sort of like that.
Yeah,
I can find this stuff like,
yeah,
well that's,
that's very interesting to me.
But what I'm really most fascinated by
is this willingness to put your life in
mortal danger
and that how exciting this
is for people to watch.
Like what's the most
viewed video that you have?
How many hits does it have?
A,
I think just over 4 million.
That's fucking people.
Yeah.
This one's got a few million.
I think this is you.
You get,
so we climbed it.
We went,
we just pushed it too far.
Like we went up to the very top platform.
If you've been to Paris,
no,
it didn't say off the top.
So you can take the lift up,
right?
You can,
you can walk.
Can you take the stairs
to the second platform?
That's the highest you
can take the stairs too.
There is stairs to the top,
but they don't allow it because
they're like weird and narrow.
And so you take the lift to the top and
then there's like a door that's manned
by a security card that is
the door to that staircase.
And that's where we came
up from the backside.
So we,
we went up and for some reason we just
had the urge to just go inside even
though it's lit up,
even though there's cameras everywhere.
We opened that door,
I step in to the top platform
and then I just hear this,
this walkie talkie just go like,
ah,
like you go crazy and French.
And I was like,
Shit,
we've definitely been
seen less disappears.
And then we ran down,
we climbed out of the
staircase and then on each,
on opposite corners of the
tower in the main beams,
there's like kind of like a little
pocket inside the beam that you can jump
into.
It must be like two by two.
Like size.
I barely fit into it,
right?
Cause I'm huge.
My friend is small.
So you just like,
Brooke disappeared into this hole and
then we sat on opposite ends of the tower
and hid and the lifts.
You start hearing lifts coming,
you're up,
you start hearing people running up
and down the stairs you see taught is
everything's kicking off and
we're hitting these little holes
and they're searching for us and I'm just
like hiding in this hole and I'm like,
I've got one shoe off
because it wouldn't fit in.
I've got my knee wrestling on my shoe,
I've lost all feeling in my leg
because the blood circulation has gone.
My head's sticking out the top and I've
got like my tee shirt over my head,
like a little Ninja and there's people
with torches going up and down looking
for us.
So do you have video,
that little pocket that you were in?
Uh,
in this now I do have is only
on two sides of the tower,
which is strange,
but it's kind of similar to this gap here.
Oh,
I see.
It's there.
I see on the right,
it's in that corner there and it's
like a foot and a half by a foot.
And a half.
I think I barely fit in.
So how long did they wait?
So we were in the [inaudible]
coming up right now.
Yeah.
This is what it was starting to open up.
This was like as we,
so this is like right where as here,
just before we go.
Yeah.
So we've tucked in,
this was just before we got caught.
So how'd you get caught?
Because the lifts start coming up cause
the staff start coming up to work or to
clean or something and they just saw us.
We're just like running around these
beams and there's lifts everywhere.
So what happens then?
So with like,
so we're still in this hole and we
sit in this whole for like two hours,
at least two hours where
they're going up and down.
It goes quiet.
So I jumped out of the hole.
I have a look around,
I go and see Stevie.
Stevie's like half asleep,
just chilling in the hole and then
come back to the whole.
I'm like,
yeah,
this seems like pretty clear now.
I think they must've thought that we
jumped off with parachutes and we,
because they couldn't find us.
And then I was like,
yeah,
this,
this seems pretty clear.
And then every single light on the tower,
because the whole thing lights up.
And this isn't like the twinkly lights
that they have on every hour at night.
This is like internal lights
that are like this big,
like the whole fucking tower up.
So I jumped straight back into the hole.
I'm not sure what's going on.
And then lifts again,
people up and down the
stairs again looking for us.
So when we sat in these
homes again for ages
and then,
and then it finally goes quiet,
but the lights are still on for a little
while and then the whole thing just
shuts down and that,
I think that was it.
So I jumped out,
I had a look around,
went and got Stevie and
then it was ours again.
And then we were up there until
like 9:00 AM I think it was.
How long was that?
How many hours?
A 1:00 AM til 9:00 AM.
Wow.
So you were climbing around and
I think for eight fucking hours,
that's nuts.
Running that French chocolate Barb.
She's really good.
Oh,
that's all you eat.
It's all we had.
Yeah.
So he came down because you were hungry.
We came down cause we got caught now.
And so you would have stayed
there for the rest of the day.
Um,
I,
the idea was to like wait till it opened
and then get into a place where you
could hide like near the second platform
and then just drop into the second
platform and just merge
in with like the tourists.
But we didn't get that far.
That would have been calm.
So the plan was to wait for it to
open and sneak out with the crowd.
Just jumped out of the
beam into the crowd,
disappears into a lift.
Done.
So when you get caught,
then what happens?
So we got seen by like a
big group of people in,
in one of the lifts and
we were just like waving.
And they're like,
ah,
like angry looking people,
but like angry people and happy people.
They're like,
what the heck's going on?
And then,
uh,
we would like to above slightly above
and maintenance platform where they have
like lifts that take workers up.
And then,
so we had to climb down and we met people
on the maintenance platform getting
the left.
There's like five of us,
like to me and Stevie and
they're like few other people,
security,
just like private security for the tower.
And then we come down to
the basement lifts open.
It's just like a room full of policemen
and we're like go see in the movie.
And when they do that bit,
I had to hide every single SD card
and everything that I had on me.
How'd you do that?
Three kinds of people.
But no,
no,
it was an option.
That was the only option.
Yeah.
I haven't had to do that yet.
But he had a condom.
You tie it in and not
put them in the condom,
put your finger up,
move on.
That's right.
All right.
So how do you,
um,
hide the SD cards?
I mean,
they must've went through
your stuff for the flight.
I thought they would,
but they didn't.
I don't know.
Paris,
they don't give a fuck,
they're turning delayed drink wine.
Chocolate had like a big
five d like a big DSLR.
And then I had I think two GoPros and so
to Mike arrestees and one like CF card
from the,
from the big one.
And I had like this bag that I
had like little tiny pen pockets,
like really thin pockets.
Right.
And I just stuffed the mark cresty
cause down there and I had like a,
a little rip in the
back padding of the bag.
So I just threw the CF card in the back
of the bag and it just fell down and I
just hoped.
And then when we got
to the police station,
they were like,
you have so many cameras on you,
clearly you've been filming.
And I was like,
no,
I forgot the SD cards.
Cameras died.
And they,
they believed that I had to
surrender everything on my phone.
I um,
he had to surrender
everything on your phone.
Yeah.
So,
so I had three cameras,
right.
So I was like,
I had three cameras and my phone,
so I like,
I'm going to have to give something
up to try and save the most valuable,
the most valuable footage.
So I was like,
they were like,
did you feel most like only filmed in
my phone because my camera's died and I
forgot my SD cards.
And then they went through like the
footage on the phone just made me delete.
Oh that's cool.
So the,
the footage and the phone was like a ruse.
The footage on the phone
was like me in the,
in the little hole filming,
talking to the camera and like filming
the people looking cause I was like this
and I put my phone out.
Great.
That you had something to give them.
Yeah.
So then what happens?
How long did they detain you?
Uh,
we were there for like eight hours,
so another eight hours hours.
So when you're eight hours
up there climbing around,
how do you pee?
You pee off the edge of the town.
Oh my God.
That's probably why I got arrested person
on his French people as if life throws
and clicked on them enough.
Yeah.
I think by the time it gets to the ground,
it's kind of all spread out and we're not,
or it's a fucking raging river of piss
around on some little Old Lady's head.
Yeah.
It seems like if you were just pee on
the tower that way it dribbles down
slowly.
It doesn't hit anybody in the head.
I mean if you were still on the Eiffel
Tower and you needed to pay and there was
no one below you because
it's like 4:00 AM oh okay.
You'd pay off the edge.
Maybe you don't know how
much that's even ruder.
I'm sorry.
Tough enough person.
If I did peel on them,
maybe it's a romantic
couple going for a walk,
maybe it would have really worked out.
All of a sudden the girl goes to the
lighter cigarette and you piss running her
head and she gets mad and the fucking
evening ends poorly and they could have,
it could have been a perfect relationship,
but you ruined it.
I killed it.
So he come down and then another
eight hours of detention.
Yeah.
And what do they do to you?
Handcuffed us to a chair.
We just sat in the middle of the,
of this police station.
There's like sales behind us with people
going crazy and like people bleeding
from the eyeballs.
And we just sat there like people
bleeding from their eyeballs,
from other crimes,
like nighttime fights and stuff
like that and just drunk people.
And we would just sat there for ages.
And then we finally got taken into like
separate rooms where we were questioned
by some high up.
I had a woman,
he had a dude and we were both questions
for a couple of hours and then we were
back out handcuffed to the chairs again.
And then they took all of our
stuff and they searched it.
And I was like,
well,
if they find it,
they're going to be like,
okay,
you just told us that you feel nothing.
And we've just found hours
and hours of footage,
like what's the deal?
So I was like,
oh,
please,
no cards.
Yeah.
And then um,
they finally brought the,
brought the bags back.
Like it must've been an hour.
They had them for,
and I thought they were going
to go through everything,
but they brought it back.
I checked it and I was like,
stomach,
the gods are still here.
And then we just like,
we just lost it.
We were so happy.
But the policemen,
I had no idea what we were doing.
So do they kick you out of the country?
They had no record.
Nothing.
It's all,
so I had to go back in that room.
I had to sign an agreement that said,
I promise I will not climb the
Eiffel Tower for three years.
For three years.
That's it.
That was it.
Yeah.
Wait,
a magnum,
right.
How can they only give you how come out?
I'll take forever.
Ever.
I
think they must like it.
Yeah.
You know what?
You're a woman that was interviewing me.
He loved it.
She did.
She was like,
you really shouldn't be doing this,
but how did you do this?
It's incredible.
Like she loved it.
Why Oak?
He loved it.
Yeah.
Well,
I think once they realize
that you're polite,
you're gentleman,
you're a very nice guy,
you're just a thrill seeker.
They're like,
okay,
this is not a threat to society,
skies,
and a terrorist.
Yeah.
So the second question she asked me was,
did you leave a bomb up there?
Oh God.
And I just laughed.
I was like,
what?
Come on.
Oh Wow.
Well,
that's something that they
have to take any consideration.
They have to actually trust you.
Right?
If they let you go,
it turns out you did leave a bottom up,
down.
Then they have to,
like,
they would have to comb over the
building with a fine tooth comb.
Who's going to say he's going to be like,
yeah,
you know what I did?
I left the boom up there.
No,
no one would write.
So they really have to trust you.
Yeah.
Fucking Europeans.
Ridiculous,
ridiculous people.
Three years.
Fuck you.
You throw me in jail forever.
It was America.
They put you right in Guantanamo Bay.
They throw a dog in there with you.
Cool.
[inaudible].